[Música]
[Aplausos]
duelo la mayoría de nosotros lo primero
que pensaremos será en la experiencia de
la muerte pero hoy quiero pedirte que me
acompañes a revisar una idea de por qué
no hay solo la muerte la única
experiencia en la vida que te puede
llevar a experimentar un duelo
un duelo o dolor emocional es eso que
sentimos cuando algo en lo que estamos
acostumbrados se interrumpe cambia o
termina entendiendo lo así entonces el
casarse tener un hijo graduarse una
mudanza cambiar de trabajo divorciarse o
la muerte de un ser querido
serían experiencias de vida que nos
pueden llevar a experimentar un duelo
dolor emocional
y si se dan cuenta algunas de las
experiencias que mencioné las tenemos
clasificadas como positivas y es por eso
que el dolor emocional es tan difícil de
tratar porque generalmente se trata de
sentimientos contradictorios si por
ejemplo yo pierdo un ser querido después
de una larga enfermedad puedo por un
lado sentir alivio de que ya no está
sufriendo pero al mismo tiempo aún
quererlo tener conmigo si termino una
relación sentimental que no es positiva
para mí puedo también sentir alivio en
mi corazón pero al mismo tiempo tener
incertidumbre de saber si volver a
encontrar el amor
como médico puedo decirles que nunca
durante mis estudios me enseñaron que
las emociones tenían importancia en la
salud
hoy con cada vez más evidencia
científica sabemos que incluso la vía
neurológica que transmite el dolor
físico es la misma que transmite el
dolor emoción
se hizo un estudio en el departamento de
neurociencias de jucilei donde colocaron
a pacientes en una resonancia magnética
con un experimento que ellos denominaron
saib erbol ellos colocaban a los
pacientes con unos goles que simulaba un
juego de cacha 2 entre tres jugadores
conforme iba avanzando el tiempo cada
vez lanzaban menos la pelota al paciente
que estaba dentro de la resonancia éste
al interpretarlo como rechazo mostraba
en las imágenes de su resonancia una
activación de las áreas del cerebro que
están relacionadas con el dolor físico
en otro estudio también dentro de una
resonancia magnética pidieron como
voluntarios a personas que hubieran
terminado una relación sentimental en
los seis meses anteriores que ellos no
hubieran querido terminar hicieron dos
secuencias en la resonancia en una veían
las pero los pacientes veían una foto de
su expareja con frases que les hiciera
recordar cómo se sentían en esa
secuencia la activación de la vía
neurológica era intensa en una segunda
secuencia las personas veían una foto de
una persona que fuera significativa para
ellos de una manera positiva y
encontraron que en esa secuencia no
había una activación
qué importante es entonces que cuando
una persona tiene dolor emocional se
sienta acompañada de una persona que es
positiva para ella y que le puede
regalar la escucha
pero no es fácil acompañar a una persona
cuando estaba con dolor emocional
generalmente nos sentimos muy estresados
nos preocupamos cuando estamos con
alguien que está llorando no sabemos qué
hacer lo vemos a los ojos nos volteamos
otro lado lo abrazo le ofrezco un
kleenex no sabemos qué hacer y esto es
porque generalmente aprendemos cómo
superar nuestras pérdidas hasta que
tenemos nosotros mismos que superar una
y además de esto es porque hay algunas
ideas que hemos aprendido mal acerca de
cómo manejar nuestro dolor emocional
la primera de estas ideas es que no es
válido sentirse mal seguramente nos ha
pasado que cuando tenemos un problema y
se lo queremos platicar a alguien lo
primero que nos dice es no te sientas
mal y entonces tenemos dos problemas el
que teníamos originalmente y el problema
de haber confiado y abierto nuestro
corazón a una persona que lo único que
hizo fue invalidar nuestro dolor y
darnos la orden de que no debemos de
sentirnos mal otra de las ideas
equivocadas es que una institución va a
arreglar el dolor que tú sientes
pensamos que si iniciamos una nueva
relación compramos una nueva mascota o
cambiamos a un nuevo trabajo el dolor se
eliminará pero es necesario saber que
mientras no solucionemos lo que queda
pendiente de esa primera relación
seguramente con lo que queramos
sustituirla no va a funcionar y
probablemente esa nueva relación
también fracase
otra de las ideas que hasta este en los
dichos populares es que no hay mal que
dure 100 años pero seguramente conocemos
personas que han pasado 5 10 o 15 años
desde que tuvieron una perdida y no se
han podido recuperar y esto es porque el
tiempo por si mismo no tiene un poder
curativo es lo que tú hagas durante ese
tiempo lo que verdaderamente te va a
llevar a sanar tu corazón
el dolor emocional lo experimentamos
todos seguramente todos hemos tenido
alguna pérdida de nuestra vida no
respeta edad sexo religión nivel de
estudios pero lo más complicado es que
pareciera que la vida es una competencia
de demostrar que somos los más fuertes
que aunque hayamos tenido una pérdida
muy difícil de superar
seguimos de pie y seguimos adelante eso
no es la verdadera fortaleza la
verdadera fortaleza es ser coherente
entre lo que piensas lo que sientes y
cómo actúas
tener dolor emocional no es un defecto
todo lo contrario
tener dolor emocional es ser sensible
empático aceptar la vulnerabilidad
humana es saber le poner nombre y
expresión a eso que está sintiendo tener
dolor emocional es tener una herida que
nadie puede ver pero que es la más
difícil de sanar
ahora entonces cómo podemos hacer para
sanar ese dolor emocional
reconoce que algo te está pasando si te
está pasando algo si perdiste algo y
tienes todo el derecho del mundo de
hablar cuantas veces necesites de él
de llorar todo lo que necesites para
aliviar tu corazón sin que te importe la
respuesta o la reacción de las personas
que están alrededor de ti
si te dicen que no es posible que
todavía estés llorando por eso que pasó
hace tanto tiempo tú tienes derecho y
necesitas hacerlo para poder sanar tu
corazón
no busques culpables buscar culpables o
estar enojado es una parte normal del
duelo
pero mientras más pronto puedas entender
o aceptar la idea de que las cosas así
son de que la vida adiós el universo en
lo que tú creas no te va a llegar un día
tocar la puerta y a preguntarte qué te
parece si hoy te quito a tu esposo qué
te parece si hoy te quito tu trabajo o
qué hoy vas a recibir el diagnóstico
enferme
la vida te confronta y es tu
responsabilidad
afrontar el reto que ella te estada
3 cuídate a ti mismo no necesitas que yo
te diga que cuando tienes dolor
emocional no puedes comer bien no puedes
dormir bien no puedes concentrarte eso
tú ya lo sabes eso tú ya lo has vivido
pero si te sirve que yo hoy te recuerde
que eres una persona valiosa que tú
estás en este mundo ocupando un lugar
que nadie más que tú puede ocupar lo que
tú tienes una misión que tienes que
cumplir y por eso sigue siendo una
persona valiosa no importa lo que haya
sucedido tú no eres una víctima tienes
que encontrar cómo sanar ese corazón y
una buena manera es cuidarte trata de
comer
acompañarte de personas que te hagan
4 vive sin pendientes si tienes ganas de
ver a alguien de hablar con alguien de
decirle que lo quieres o de perdonarlo
hazlo y hazlo hoy porque hoy es el único
día que tienes seguro ni tú ni yo
sabemos si mañana tendremos la
oportunidad de decir eso que para ti hoy
es importante y quién no lo hace es
quién se queda con asuntos emocionales
que después causan un dolor y que
después tiene que resolver
y por último pide ayuda no es de débiles
pedir ayuda todo lo contrario yo siempre
le digo a mis pacientes que es de
valientes sentarse en un consultorio
hablar con un desconocido sobre eso que
tú sabes que te duele pero que quiere
sanar los tanatólogos somos esos
profesionales que estamos especializados
en acompañar a otros en sus procesos de
pérdida por medio de una escucha activa
esto es escuchar sin juzgar sin analizar
sin interrumpir sin criticar la escucha
activa definitivamente
o regalo que se le puede dar
para terminar de armar un rompecabezas
de una vida plena y feliz
una parte indispensable y fundamental
sería saber que el dolor emocional es
real que nuestras emociones son
importantes
tan importante es que
en nuestra salud
y que no es un defecto
y que siempre se puede sanar el dolor de
un corazón
cuando tiene el regalo de la escucha
activa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]